I don't blame women for doing that at
all I don't either it's I think it's
like [ __ ] yeah you shouldn't condition
because I was gonna Rob her so she
[ __ ]
[Music]
and welcome back to another what will be
for sure a legendary episode of the
careful boys and today
we have Colleen here
which means we need to use this
opportunity to just ask a woman's stuff
just talk to a lady we get to talk to a
girl we're gonna talk to a girl today
I'm we're all nervous dude
don't be nervous don't be shy dude you
got questions Nick go ahead I don't have
any questions Nick you got to start off
you really wanted to talk to a girl
today yeah you know so we love when
there's every girl's face when a guy
starts off that way
uh in the room
we just don't know how to talk to ladies
in the room because we don't see them
all the time you know I have a question
mark has a question oh my God take it
away you know in the movies in the
movies the the dudes they're always able
to like they meet a girl like oh [ __ ]
and then there's like that just that
initial reaction somehow people can get
someone else's number has that ever
happened to you before where it's not
through a mutual friend or multiple
occurrences it's like the movies like at
a bar pick up line
has it ever happened
um
giggling like that
guys carrying too much stuff yeah yeah
oh no
oh god oh let me get oh let me give you
my number yeah
what the [ __ ] oh whoa hi hi hi hi hi hi
hi hi hi hello how are you my name's
Steve right I just feel like the the
instinctive thing to do there would be
to give you my number has that ever
happened
to do I knew it yeah has anyone ever
like cold called and then gotten your
number what do you mean cold call they
don't have my number yet stupid he's
talking about scammers like do scammers
do scammers hey uh you have an unpaid
electric bill you got to send me money
you're like hi I think we should
actually meet for a date it's like but
you sound nice
forget this forget my job let's just go
let's run off together all right let me
give you my number
but you can feel it coming right like
most girls can feel that yeah it happens
at the gym oh okay and you've never
given it out do you give [ __ ] wrong
numbers
um no I'll give them like my Instagram
oh that's nice okay and then when you
give them your Instagram is that more of
like a Pity thing like I don't want to
deal with it or is it like we'll see
where this goes I have no expectations
so like if they want it I'll give it to
them but to be honest I don't think
about it unless I'm attracted to them do
they have to earn it though do they got
to do something like make you laugh yeah
they gotta do like three reps of 325.
but they gotta yell too right they gotta
be like
they have to scream give me your number
the last rep yeah it's on the last rep
and if they fail oh you're right or if
they hit a PR then it's like all right
cool if they drop the bar like on the
ground does your [ __ ] just flood out
usually
I [ __ ] knew it yeah dude girls love
that [ __ ] so so if you are attracted to
them do you go past your hygiene give
them your number it depends on what they
ask for they gotta make the move they
gotta make the move huh that's what it
is well if they're the one initiating it
they're already making the move that's
true what if they just say hey how can I
reach you and you really like them like
they're [ __ ] cool that I'd be like
are you dumb what do you mean how can
you reach me we're talking right now
you're mean to every dude you your neck
guy no one has a chance I know I'm
talking to you right now but how can I
reach you I gotta reach your heart you
ever give somebody your LinkedIn and say
your Instagram
[Laughter]
actually I'm on LinkedIn oh
Myspace as as a spokeswoman for all
women out there for all women
in your opinion who are the five hottest
celebrities right now top five top five
out of two but only say two and why
um I'm already from Power oh wait who's
that the show Power Omarion Omarion
Omarion what's the actor's name
uh Omari adeleke oh yeah okay yeah Amari
Hardway he's the one with the bro
I will show a photo give me one second
can you name the other top five out of
two five out of two yes
um oh wait why though you didn't oh yeah
because I'm tricks because he's [ __ ]
crazy or whatever also Dion Cole
Dion Cole Dion Cole yeah the comedian's
[ __ ] hilarious hilarious he's so
[ __ ] funny dude he's he's on he was
on blackish as a character and he's the
red so he's the red red spice Old Spice
he's the Old Spice guy oh he's [ __ ]
hilarious I need to watch more [ __ ] I
don't know and that's my five out of two
dude Dion Cole's really funny oh so I
see that base off of both of these
individuals it seems like you happen to
have a thing for actors facial hair for
facial hair for facial hair yeah I don't
know why the [ __ ] smallest photos
keep on pulling up yeah cool is really
funny he is really cool I can see that
like yeah it's a good look he's like
he's right for Conan too bro yeah he did
yeah he was a writer yeah the stand-up's
good too in your opinion as well what
about females top five out of two female
uh Margot Robbie
and um that's just a fire that's just
the facts
Kathy Bates Kathy Bates
um Cheryl soups
I'll name them for you yeah yeah I know
Ryan's got Ryan's got some good choices
over there he took my five out of two
yeah yeah yeah she got no more left none
Meryl Streep oh actually
on Meryl Streep you're the first chick
who doesn't like Aquaman every chick I
talked about that's like the given
that's the is it hacky now does that
look very it's he's so hot that it's
hacky well she's saying it's given he's
already built into the foundation
everybody knows okay he's attractive but
for me there's more things that go into
attractiveness like take Dion Cole for
an example like
the fact that he's actually funny and he
writes for Conan just that got it there
it is that's all I need what about Conan
then the guy he writes for you is he hot
what about his monologue oh yeah it's
Conan yeah
it's a given it's a given it's baked in
the foundation you can clearly see my
pattern yeah so yeah Dion Cole Cody
O'Brien I love funny guys there it is go
pick it up when I'm putting down up
there too out of the places that chicks
frequent
which one is the place where if someone
wanted to pick up on a chick is the most
successful that's the higher chance okay
yeah setting at the spot so it's jamming
or I don't know wherever you get your
coffee or gas station like the typical a
terrible I guess what feels the least
creepy yeah
[Music]
uh some sort of environment that we're
what that act is so like a gym at the
gym probably probably because then
you're like great you you also take care
of your body so that's that's a good
foundation but what if he's using the
thighs thing and he's hogging in all the
girls are waiting for him and he's like
when I'm finished and his name is Conan
it's recorded yeah and he writes for
Conan
in other places
work how about work stuff yeah do you
have a rule about that do you not like
fraternize with like people that are
like a [ __ ] great steps on set yeah
that's a difference yeah okay what if
you
have a banging little Teamster and he's
like offset banging little Teamster
immediately I was like turned off when
you said that oh you're and then you're
like yo you're a union that's crazy
you know yo you sag dog you said what's
up but that's different because your
mind's not even on that [ __ ] when you're
on the job huh yeah and I think um
Murphy's like a yoked line producer
he's like Jack yeah he's like absolutely
Jack and he's showing you videos of him
benching 325 his neck muscles have neck
muscles he's in PR every day
or when the [ __ ] guy does a slate it
breaks every time [ __ ] mom he can't
even move no he can't move his head
yes
[Laughter]
he has too much muscles going on it's
like the idea of guys trying to show off
because she's there and the [ __ ] boom
mic guy puts weights on the end and he's
like yeah I've got it he's doing it hey
why did you always be there the boom my
guy is yeah he's always there that's who
he thinks deserves a shot oh yeah you
gotta give the boom my guy I imagine
boom my guys will always be super buff
yeah dude have you ever uh I don't know
what do you think about meeting someone
in an uberpool
already share it you're a great a rich
guy yeah of course a rich guy asked that
yeah
keep your privilege at the door sir he's
all you share the helicopter it's like
public transportation oh the private jet
you mean when you share on the private
jet that's what this guy's talking about
Bart's like they still do take buses
why why do they do that just jet sweet X
around like me I'm Mark Quan
how did you win your last dude like meet
initially through the industry oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I [ __ ] where I eat I [ __ ] where I work
hey hey in my defense it was a different
industry still entertainment but
different industry oh adult
entertainment that's right that's right
what's the uh most interesting or
surprising place you met someone
like it caught you off guard like oh I
never thought I'd meet someone here meet
somebody like somebody that like it
turned into something yeah yeah like I
should have turned into something
surprising place I don't know they're
all pretty generic to be expected it's
not like I was like swimming in the
ocean and like he was two and we're like
hey what was what was the that's kind of
romantic how come you don't have more
stories like that Colleen all right I'll
make one up
it's just kind of like what the [ __ ]
what what is generic though what's like
what's yeah what's a generic spot
uberpool
like you go to work you go to the gym
you go to a restaurant like these are
things that we all do right
I don't go to the gym the gym is not on
yeah you watch it I'm not gonna go
even though somebody said not somebody a
woman that you really enjoyed
like Martha Stewart you can't change me
[ __ ]
I said I'll give you my number if you go
to the gym you can't change I got
numbers I got a whole [ __ ] phone in
numbers
I got numbers and numbers what about a
Margot Robbie what about a Margot
do you guys that coin market cap yeah do
you guys even remember the last time
that you like
got a number
do you even remember that's like so
[ __ ] long ago do you think people
approach people in person more these
days or is it strictly online like
online dating and apps and all that
stuff like social media online do you
think we've gone into a stage of society
where people are uh more inclined to
meet people online than they are in
person I think so I feel like you one
you a lot of interaction happens there
right you're commenting on people's
Pages whether it's platonic or romantic
whatever just having a good time online
and then I think it gives people the
comfort of like getting to know someone
from afar with a boundary yeah because
some people might feel like really
anxious or I don't want to meet someone
in person and there's all this pressure
versus I can go oh I can see what the
hell kind of person Nick is from my
[ __ ] little stalker like spy
perspective which is also kind of weird
at the same time but you can get more
into the intimate while being further
away if that makes sense that's true I
have I have heard from like a lot of
guys climate wise that it's it's less uh
like really eligible good dudes tend to
not cold talk women for Fears of like it
being creepy or that they'll get
complaints so they're just more like
standoffish like in in real life in real
life in real life Boulders they're
afraid of of making somebody
uncomfortable even though they're
interested don't you think that's a
little sad that we've gone to a place
where men think that just having a
conversation with a woman will equal
creepiness I think it's sad I think
that's extremely sad that we've lost
ability to have any kind of conversation
when I'm walking like in my neighborhood
and [ __ ] if there's like a woman like
around while I'm walking I even just
feel weird there because like I can feel
like she maybe feels threatened or
something because there's just two of
you like that yeah because just like
both of us and like say I'm walking I
have the longest ride and she's like
tiny and like came up around her you're
also wearing a woo necklace that's Iced
Out in a giant tiger neon she's walking
by like that guy's Rich I'm dripping all
over I'm blinking heart no question I'm
styling I'm profiling but yeah
I try to make sure that she knows that
like I'm cool yeah so I like I yeah so
what do you how do you walk if you're
gonna be cool yeah well I'm already
walking pretty cool you know not
non-threatening
hello there that's what we need is a we
need a non-threatening male pageant yeah
even if you're uh in the same Community
you feel that too of course because they
don't we don't all know each other like
especially like in my community it's
it's like a bunch of communities in one
area but you guys know that like you
guys live there I assume they think I
live there this lady got scared by me
the other day I was walking you're a
scary looking dude why am I though like
a five two I was walking in my car and I
was just standing behind this this lady
and then she kept looking over her
shoulder and just like walking fast and
I was like dude I'm just walking on my
car I don't blame women for doing that
at all I don't either it's I think it's
like [ __ ] yeah you shouldn't condition
because I was gonna Rob her so she
[ __ ] sucks at that I was gonna steal
her purse it sucks at that scenario and
then I did
and I did I stole from her and it was
like I wish there was a way like that
she knew like I'm cool I'm a married guy
just trying to walk around I'm like I'm
a cool guy but he just walks around like
this the whole time yeah I do think it's
dependent on my community though like
like Bart was even alluding to you it's
like if you uh come in come from a
community or area where the neighborhood
like knows each other then there's like
your guard's a little bit more down
right but I can imagine in La it's like
everyone's guard should be up all the
[ __ ] time out here yeah for sure
period you know and that probably is
similar to even like the has he gone to
a society where like everybody's more
comfortable with like digital dating
versus whatever I also think we're in
like a super dense like Melting Pot like
Los Angeles area where yeah I think
digital dating makes more sense you do
need to uh be the anti-creeper and you
need to like to vet you know like right
into that pocket right away because
everybody's guards up here especially as
a lady you got a vet way more no but I
could imagine like a much more rural
area or region or even like just being a
foreigner or something like that you
know because it's weird in weird way
like all almost foreigners to this place
but imagine being into you know in
another country where almost all the
inhabitants are like one nation I bet
you they're guards in a completely
different place or the way they approach
it is different versus just like online
dating or not you know what I mean yeah
but I think La [ __ ] [ __ ] no guards up
like you have to you have to stalk and
vet everyone out to like the umpteenth
degree you have to look up then how do
you get to know someone or how do you
like get to like I think I think the
vetting goes like at that stalker level
and then that's kind of like step one
that's like back in the day we used to
maybe just
say hi yeah but now it's like you have
to fully stock somebody's entire resume
and then if they're good then you can
try to say hi okay so here's a real life
situation like let's say this dude is
literally like the coolest dude he's
awesome he's wholesome but he doesn't
have the skill set of Crossing that
border yet versus a lot of the scumbags
at the bar because they're so they have
so many reps in
um they're actually a scumbag but
they're really good at Crossing people's
uh like their walls like how do how does
the good guy who wants to be able to get
to and talk to people even not just
chicks but just get to be friends with
people in general since everyone's walls
are up how does he
go past people's walls so they can just
connect us people that just sounds like
life dude yeah I think I think we talked
about that before about
putting yourself in situations that
you're interested in the same topics
that the other people are or you're
doing the same activity that you're
interested in that other people are so
it it engages a conversation that's
already natural yeah like what if I was
like hey uh I actually really like chick
movies like I loved it and then I was
like Hey like I actually really like um
tiger jumpsuits I happen to have a
couple yeah I have a couple it's it's
really like it sucks at like um a big
hack for a lot of that is just being
really good looking oh yeah just be good
looking it's I mean that sucks it sucks
because it's like it's like for like I
was watching some interview where they
were interviewing women about like oh do
you think it's creepy when like guys
come up and talk to you and do that and
they're all like yeah that's so creepy
and they're like what if it's this guy
and then they're like oh that's
different it's like what
you were talking about him
[Laughter]
but but also guys are the same way like
it's we we treat women the exact same
way if like some we're getting cold
talked to by some girl we don't think is
attractive it's like all right [ __ ]
hurry up get on with it but it's also
less threatening that's all the less
threat exactly yeah it is there's like
something kind of some weird thing
that's attached to that like oh this
person's good looking so they're
probably less of a threat they're
probably more of a pleasure there's like
all this [ __ ] that's attached so what
would be your advice to people who are
speaking to Attractive people like how
do you get over that I guess anxiety or
that perception that this person has
more value than I do nobody's better
than you ever yeah who comes after
everyone's butt too bro yeah that's it
that girl that you think is done we all
came out of the same Canal at the end of
the day brother she gets diarrhea too
that's what I think
that's how I talked about that's how I
met my lady I was like hey she poops out
of her butt too man I mean it it
definitely sucks because like there's
times where I felt like
um like because when I used to be super
into cars like massively into cars this
uh usually it'd be really easy for me to
meet another girl that had a really cool
like vintage car at a gas station or
some [ __ ] because we could instantly
talk about it but then there was this
point but I thought it's all rare too
though right but then that's like an
easy jump off point but then there was
this one time I was at a gas station
this girl had like a dope like 60s
Mustang and that particular day I
happened to be in sweat and driving a
U-Haul and it did not work my
conversation didn't work I wasn't
talking to her about her cars yeah and
she was just like the [ __ ] is this crazy
she's like why would I talk to a guy
who's moving out of town yeah
you look like a [ __ ] yeah that's like
Ryan in his outfit right now though
right if he jumps out of a [ __ ]
Camaro it's like this was badass but if
he jumps out at U-Haul I'd be like dude
this guy's down on his luck I just look
like I'm gonna [ __ ] Obama Hospital
dude
of value is important got it my Uber
driver asked me if I was an artist today
are you some kind of artist and I was
like yeah yeah did they ask you more
follow-up questions I said mostly clay
based
he's the new Riff Raff I make Pueblos
but dude appearance is like such a giant
part of it it's crazy but dude do you
think Momoa
like because speaking of hot guys doing
creepy things do you think that Momoa
could just drive like by you roll down
his window and go let's see those
titties and like tricks are like oh my
God
whereas most dudes if you do that it's
like holy [ __ ] they're gonna call the
police
[Music]